[Music]
[Applause]
that's henry cavill in the witcher
season two is streaming now on netflix
after a two-year wait henry returned to
the white wig and intense training to
bring back his sword-wielding monster
hunter geralt with geralt i tried to
make him come across as intellectual um
wise i mean he's been around for 70 plus
years so he's going to have a sense of
wisdom
well let's turn now from the world of
fantasy to a series that showcases paris
fashion and then some you like that
michelle absolutely
we're gonna work on our accents we're
trying but season two of emily
does premiere tomorrow and this go round
emily is definitely coming in
and ever since i moved to paris my life
has just been chaotic and dramatic and
complicated
we have love triangles give me your best
season two teas because so much happens
a lot of love geometry all shapes all
triangle rectangle square this is just
such a huge mess the show faced backlash
for lack of cultural diversity but
producer and star lily collins tells us
the golden globe nominated series will
be more immersed in french culture we
wanted to have emily embracing more of
the fabric that makes up the city of
paris which is the people she meets the
food she eats the language she speaks
all of the above and all of the above
includes lots of fashion lily's first
emily in paris season two fitting took
seven hours you walk into a room and
it's just covered with fabric and colors
and prints and designs i mean every
episode has about
10 outfits so it takes a lot of time to
get those right especially after having
worn sweatpants for a year and a half
being comfortable and all of a sudden
it's like oh fashion what is that
now how many costumes do you think you
wore
in season two oh my god i don't know
like i would say 30. probably half the
amount that she does but yeah
what are your plans brother nothing of
note
other than finding and promptly
declaring my intentions to my new
contest
well bridgerton fans will have to wait
to watch anthony bridgerton's love story
unfold but hey it's even more reason to
re-binge season one right but if you
think season two won't be as sexy as the
first
thing again
you
pardon me my lord
i never got your name
i was wondering if we'd meet again
jonathan bailey fans rejoice the entire
season will revolve around his courtship
of newcomer simone ashley are you
prepared for things to blow up for you
now that you are the main character well
you know i'm really happy at the moment
receiving messages uh on instagram yeah
it's just an exciting moment i think for
everyone are the young ladies of london
truly so easily won by a pleasing smile
and absolutely nothing more so you find
my smile pleasing i find your opinion of
yourself entirely too high and expect
some steamy scenes between these two in
fact this cast is so pumped for what's
ahead that penelope aka lady whistled
down dropped this tidbit about their
secret text chain it's the new season
two group chat was going off it's called
bridger ii
that name i felt very proud i felt like
that's so smart mama would never allow
me to wear a dress like this their
costumes are ridiculous this season they
are stunning beyond stunning season two
wrapped shooting in november and while
reggae jean paige has officially exited
the show he did tease a cameo telling gq
in september quote isn't there something
wonderful about being surprised by what
you weren't suspecting i want to show
you more well i'm sure with whistle down
still on the list next season will be
far more interesting where will we find
penelope in season two it's gotten a
whole lot spicier i would say
you how much can i say it's extremely
dramatic claudia jessie and i who plays
eloise literally sat in my trailer and
people are gonna die when this happens
and they're gonna die and this happened
they're not gonna believe that and it's
it's amped it's very epic this year
yay well that tracks because michelle
people who have read the bridgerton
books say that the second story is even
saucier and the love is even more
intense
give me all the sauce because i want it
all well you know what the show that
took over bridgeton's top spot as the
most stream show on netflix squid game
is definitely getting a season two
i'm in the middle of brainstorming yeah
i mean
after this huge success
i mean we gotta do something about
season two rice well we'll just all be
sitting over here with baited breath
meanwhile it has been two long years
since we last saw the marvelous mrs
maisel well good news everybody our girl
midge will soon return for season four
here she is world no more opening act
gigs what
so here's the first thing you need to
know milo ventimiglia's got a guest spot
and from these photos it looks like
sparks are flying between him and midge
you're so welcome it was so much fun i
mean milo's a consummate professional
and a sheer delight the world's biggest
flirt i mean milo wooed
every single person on this set from our
boom operator to the paparazzi down the
street to the costumers i mean
he's a real charmer oh this show's
amazing
milo reunites with his gilmore girls
bosses amy and daniel palladino who
produce maisel so does kelly bishop who
will appear in at least one episode
they've both mastered the paladino's
trademark fast talk style but it's
something milo's this is us co-star
sterling k brown had to get used to you
hate it you do it and then you get paid
he gave me grievance with it he was like
mom you should have told me like you
know every word and speaking at a pace
and i'm like i forgot i'm sorry sorry
sorry sorry man sorry
here's what else we know rachel
brosnahan's real-life husband jason
ralph will make an appearance on the
show and the new season picks up in the
1960s right where the last one left off
great timing rachel's been sharing sneak
peeks from the set since the series
started filming almost a year ago and
while new seasons usually debut in
november we won't get to see the amazon
series until february 18th production
was delayed because of kovit i did not
want that to happen but it did happen
and i had to do something about it and
by the way in its three seasons mazel
has received 20 emmys and i kind of feel
like ted lasso is on that same type of
trajectory oh yeah they're already on
and off and running
listen they're a seven time emmy winner
production on season three starts next
month so if you have not jumped on the
ted lasso train yet man get your ticket
and believe
carol's christmas chair i ended up
putting this whole sack of goodies on
the wrong sled
and a santa claus siding
[Music]
[Applause]
catch all the sweet holiday feels in
season two's christmas episode and if
you need other reasons to binge well
here's three
one ted's the ultimate optimus and you
can tell star jason sedakis loves the
role it's fun to improvise just the
fun to view the world through that lens
hey look this car's got an invisible
steering wheel i had no idea that that
people were going to be
so so wonderfully thirsty for it you
know and keep wanting to go back for
refills number two ted's all about
teamwork i'm ted lasso your new coach
great ensemble cast is is one of the
secrets of our success that includes
this year's emmy winners brett goldstein
and hannah wattingham yeah well we're
pals we all are we all are we dig each
other it's really really nauseating
season three of ted lassa which streams
on apple tv plus isn't expected to
premiere until the summer of 2022 which
leads us to the third reason to binge
ted's got staying power can we just put
all this nonsense to bed about season
three being the end i feel like a real
coach we can't look at season four when
we're in the middle of season three we
gotta take it one game at a time i could
see a spin-off like
rebecca and keely take whatever a new
yeah like a new crime fighting duo like
cagney
i love that idea
remember when john cena showed up to the
suicide squad we were wearing his
peacemaker costume well get ready
because he'll be rocking it again for
his new tv series he just likes wearing
that thing everywhere he goes doesn't it
yeah he does uh john is giving us a
super hero size sneak peek at his hbo
max spin-off take care everybody bye-bye
i thought you're in prison for life i
work for the government post office do
you think they let me out of prison to
deliver mail the studio and they
greenlit a series on a character that
has never been seen
at all by an audience and the first time
that's ever happened you can check out
peacemaker on hbo max starting january
13th i get to be a damn superhero i'm
not going to say that there aren't days
that i put on that chrome helmet and be
like
i find myself in those days that are
that are taxing i just remind myself of
three things that i'm grateful for
and that really helps me move forward
with the day
[Music]